negli episodi precedenti
hanno fatto un sacco di film vicino a
questa cascata addirittura hunger gay io
e la mia vita
ma cos'è sto male non si vede niente
striscie devo strisciare ma che cazzo me
l'ha fatto fare
la vj originals ai tagli alle gambe e
sono uscito
ciao
no sono impazzito ragazzi non l'ho fatto
davvero
piccolo sto buco ma laddove sono uscito
marlene che nessuno è mai venuto qua
nessuno ve lo dico io no l'avevano non
c'è niente destra inning bene penso di
essere arrivato nel posto più isolato di
tutte le hawaii adesso devo tornare
tutto indietro perché il problema che
non ci sono modi per lo più uscire
l'unico è tornare lì qualcuno ha
disegnato anche sta roba
inquietantissimo come faccio entrare
quale ebbe e piccoli ragazzi non so se
si capisce movimento invece
cioè mi arriva al fringuello
curata da elena
ogni volta rifareste qui granate a me
che ciò 30 anni cristo re e vabbè pure
si sono solo rayban da 3.000 euro e un
pezzo di legno qua addirittura una
vecchia miniera ma che cacchio vesto
posto ciao ragazzi in via perché più
interventi sul minimo qualcuno che so io
dai
madonna raga
mai più una cosa mai più e quindi
ragazzi mi molo per tutto il popolo
italiano e proviamo st kucka da pizza
quadra bagna cauda ma come
sono dalle hawaii per mangiare a bagna
cauda questa cosa mi fa impazzire io ero
lì ero lì il giorno in cui la forza
degli uomini 20 min a cancellare i
preconcetti ok facciamo finta che io
questo passaporto italiano non ce
l'abbia facciamo finta che non serva
mattarella la prego non li tolga la
cittadinanza perché sennò un disastro
proviamoci sento dei sapori mistici mi
sa che sto per morire come se non
bastasse hanno messo eros ramazzotti di
sottofondo
l'ananas se non altro è km zero e la
pizza che km 20 mila
che cazzo è questo un rosario
che dire bollettini e folletti né nella
mia vita di challenge non fatte
l'ho fatto questa o mandato anche la
foto a mio amico pizzaiolo napoletano
vediamo una risposta ore ma che è stati
si immergono passo davanti casa
distrutto tutto resta
the best thing i ever had my life è il
penultimo giorno ho deciso di fare una
roba un po più pazzerella siccome le
hawaii sono grandi ma non così grandi le
puoi girare tutte in macchina però ci
metti una giornata intera per cui ho
affittato una macchina che dovrebbe
essere questa sblocca
technology è questa un cavolo tipo 100
dollari un giorno non è tanto quante
macchine guidate in suo viaggio
[Musica]
ho sbagliato strada
allora signori adesso andiamo a mangiare
perché ho preso il pranzo mi sono
fermato a prendere un pranzo take away
burcu
mondo mancina marci
inizia perché qua c'è il freno a mano e
qua
ecco le canzoni macchina c'è il freno a
mano di sempre al pedale nord mamma mia
stavolta macchia nell'oceano oddio staff
a spider ne chesta spiderman e regala lo
spiderman hawaiano
marijuana
mi sono ammazzato tutto a posto ragazza
tutto a posto madonna che spiaggia direi
che con questa le abbiamo viste tutte ma
proprio tutte tutte
porca vacca che viaggia
non c'è un euro è illegale che faccio
non può esistere starò sono scioccato
credo di essere arrivato un punto
ragazzi dove già finite cioè non c'è più
e inizia solo qualche quindi ho tutti i
gusti per vedere cosa c'è dopo o non lo
puoi vedere
allora mosche dentro il mio pranzo e ci
si gode la vita so se vi ricordate
quando ai tempi lottavamo per far capire
che fare di più per comunque un lavoro
faticoso per farvi un esempio non mi
hanno messo i tovaglioli dentro il
pranzo uno può vivere così no questa
sofferenza non volevo spiegare
l'obiettivo di oggi e fare tutta l'isola
della uai la principale sulla costa con
la macchina ok ho appena visto dalla
mappa che qualche chilometro più avanti
c'è una caverna
ok ecco mi hanno detto che devo superare
quel guard rail non so come sia
possibile seconda mia mi ammazzo
bellissimo c'è una cavea è una gigante
ma scusa che modo è per una show car è
bellissima e spavento
madonna ha mai visto una cosa avesse lo
capisco il personaggio in the forest che
ogni volta che camminavo cribbio si
pagava addosso allora per martini tra
seconda ho visto qualcosa che si muove
io vado via
vado via se
avevo visto qualcosa muoversi mai non
avete visto niente lo so che
mi pare vi giuro meno male che sono
all'entrata ok non ho idea di che cosa
io abbia visto però non era piccola e
quello al fatto no no no signori e va
bene così
direi che va bene così usciamo andiamo
un'altra parte
bene
ecco lo sapevo ne ha detto abbiamo
capito ma mi devo far girare l'isola
come faccio minchia raga con in gta
strada chiusa che palle non ancora
sbloccato quest'area allora ho fatto
dietrofront e adesso vedo se riesco a
trovare un modo per aggirare il blocco
[Musica]
raga non ho la più pallida idea di dove
io sia finito un macchie casa della
madonna sono in mezzo al nulla vicino
alla riva e sono riuscito a fare il giro
credo di essere arrivato in un punto
decente allora
vedo delle dei paracadute
assurdo trova il pertugio si infila
proprio lui
si
e poi laggiù pale eoliche variati quello
zio che ha fin quando
in via
malta ma vabbè su per
lui ho ripreso tutto da dio quando le
scarpe addirittura la spiaggia sembra
che debba renderizzati questa pensa
ancora che non c'ha le texture non so
chi abiti qua hai vinto tu nella vita
darei qualsiasi cosa per aiutare io qui
qualsiasi praga ma secondo voi questo è
un animale poi una roba tipo da mangiare
che va bene ragazzi sto tornando alla
macchina ho preso un corallo forse ho il
tempo di fermarmi in un'altra spiaggia
raga ma che ca mea mea ma che adesso e
strade dragon ball ma con stiamo
arrivando alla fine di una strada che
dovrebbe dare sull'oceano
cinema che cinema
bellissimo ho fatto ricerche è
bellissimo c'è un altro dei punti più
belli di tutte le hawaii secondo me che
questi giornali che ha proprio un nome
cui collo a islanda con la prese qua
maria josé è molto simpatico ci penso io
adesso
apple in go into the beautiful click to
take a shot del video and and bust
scoglio gigante
siamo ai confini del mondo anche qua è
quindi ragazzi siamo finalmente tornati
al punto di partenza non era una mustang
perché non lo era ma ha servito
benissimo queste otto ore quindi end of
reservation ho finito tipo quattro ore
prima non so se mi scala dei soldi
vediamo non doma scala dunga ha sempre
pagato quello che grazie portata prima
in frega niente infine signori qui si
chiude la nostra vacanza alle hawaii
cioè vedere questo mare per l'ultima
volta
incredibile quindi dico addio questo
mare ma questo era il mio percorso alle
hawaii e di base il mio viaggio negli
stati uniti dovrebbe finire qua però non
è così durante il mio periodo hawaiano
quindi durante questi ultimi cinque
giorni surimi dice che a los angeles c'è
un festival chiamato che io già conosco
che si chiama con cella e mi chiede se
voglio andare con lui al coachella e che
fai
pico change ho preso questo cia ora
eccomi oscuro
[Musica]
problema che è stazionario